les thèmes complètement abstraits parce
qu'il est collectionneurs qui
collectionne par exemple les techniques
de crimes parfait ou les escroqueries
légales
à votre avis
quel est l'air de la dernière guerre
mondiale le corset de Marie-Antoinette
du temps où elle avait encore la tête
sur les épaules une pincée de safran
véritable faisant le pendant à quelques
grammes de safran scandaleusement
trafiqués le chapeau que Grand-père mit
un beau jour pour séduire votre aïeul ou
une locomotive grandeur nature crachant
sa vapeur sur des rails d'origine aucun
me direz-vous sinon que chacun de ces
éléments disparate peut faire l'objet
d'une étonnante collection prenons un
camembert par exemple une seule boîte
finit agréablement un repas deux ou
trois formes d'un généreux plateau de
fromage mais quand il y en a plus de
2000 comme chez Madame Belline c'est une
autre affaire
[Musique]
comment s'appelle la collection de
boîtes de camembert la tire aussi
combien de temps collectionnez-vous les
boîtes de camembert une douzaine
d'années uniquement les étiquettes de
camembert
[Musique]
je crois que c'était une anecdote imagée
en l'occurrence c'était celle-ci
le voyageur j'ai trouvé cette image
tellement drôle
j'ai eu l'idée de la garder et puis j'en
ai gardé une autre et puis de ce fait
j'ai commencé l'une deux trois dix et
puis j'ai eu envie d'acheter des
étiquettes beaucoup plus anciennes et
vous en êtes
je dois en avoir entre 1500 et 2000 à
présent et votre famille ne se lasse pas
de manger du camembert à tous les repas
ah non les gens j'en prends
régulièrement mais enfin pas plus pour
ça alors rouge Jean-Claude Baudot sont
les collectionneurs que vous
collectionnez en quelque sorte en fait
je me suis amusé à un moment donné il y
a une quinzaine d'années à lire les
petites annonces qui concernaient les
collectionneurs parce que je cherchais
justement des collectionneurs de
machines à sous des homologues et là
j'ai découvert que tout ce collectionné
c'était un inventaire à la Prévert qu'on
collectionner les dé à coups dans les
épingles à nourrissent n'importe quoi et
je me suis amusé à les fichier en
quelque sorte pour en faire quelque
chose et j'ai l'idée de faire un
annuaire qui est en fait cet annuaire un
annuaire des collectionneurs le wouswat
ou qui répertorie environ 15000
collectionneurs dans tous les domaines
ça va du timbre poste au tableau
impressionniste en passant par les
locomotives réelles mais également les
locomotives jouaient en fait tout il y a
7 centaines de collections
par exemple les techniques de crimes
parfait ou les escroqueries légales vous
avez également une collectionneuse des
collections des sables de tous les pays
du monde de toutes les rivières les
petits bocaux comme ça l'arménagé
d'ailleurs dans son living elle a tout
un mur de sable alors il y en a qui
collectionne par exemple les éléphants
les éléphants trompent relever
uniquement de moins de 15 cm en fait
c'est très très précis si vous voulez ou
au contraire c'est extrêmement large
[Musique]
je chasse le papillon depuis de
nombreuses années le papillon politique
le papillon politique
qu'est-ce que c'est que le papillon
politique ce sont ce n'est pas l'affiche
ce n'est pas la fichette c'est le petit
document que les militants des
différentes parties etc
le long des murs pour faire leur
propagande et comment faites-vous pour
les récupérer ces papillons politiques
je me promène avec une un couteau très
effilée si les papillons sont collés sur
des épaisseurs de la fiche à ce
moment-là je coupe autour vous savez
comme une croûte de fromage et je
décolle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous promener avec une femme aussi parce
que vous avez votre technique ah ça
c'était pendant l'occupation pendant
l'occupation je me promenais avec une
camarade de camping et on faisait
semblant de s'embrasser quand on
rencontrait un papillon on faisait
semblant de s'embrasser et je décoller
derrière son dos le dit papillon
[Musique]
une flamme sacrée
au monde du sol natal
et la France enivrée
te salue Marie
c'est quelquefois dangereux ce genre de
collection on peut tomber sur des
militants mal embouchés qui vous font
une grosse tête ça ça peut arriver
[Musique]
comment devient-on et pourquoi
devient-on collectionneur ah ben je
crois qu'on ne devient pas
collectionneur mais qu'en fait nous
sommes tous collectionneurs ça veut dire
quelque chose qui ne plaît pas beaucoup
parce que en fait il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ne collectionnent pas qui donc
n'admettent pas que l'on soit
collectionneur sans le savoir et en fait
je crois qu'on est collectionneurs d'une
façon plus ou moins consciente ou plus
ou moins inconsciente il suffit que je
sais pas moi que vous alliez si vous
retournez chez vous vous ouvrez un
tiroir vous allez découvrir qui a 5
briques et ou qui a dit portent plumes
ou qu'il y a enfin des 15 broches
c'était déjà un début de collection
seulement on n'est pas conscient puis à
un moment donné on prend conscience de
quelque chose de très particulier qui
est l'esprit de série c'est qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'on a une série d'objets ou
document qui auront un rapport entre eux
ça peut être un rapport complètement je
veux dire complètement subjectif
complètement abstrait par exemple on
peut très bien collectionner les objets
rouges de moins de 15 cm
pourquoi pas vous avez aussi les
collections qui se font pour des raisons
professionnelles par exemple un opticien
va collectionner des lunettes une
orthophoniste collectionnera les
coordonnées acoustiques vous allez
collections qui se manifestent par le
l'hérédité c'est à dire que vous avez
des parents qui ont collectionnés par
exemple des miniatures ou des livres
rares et on continue la collection du
père ou du grand père
si vous êtes dans l'escalier il fait
noir vous voyez rien vous prenez votre
petite boîte 1 2 3
4 et vous craquez la bougie et j'ai
commencé cette collection étant enfant
vers 1930 en ramorçant les billets que
vous voyez ici et puis en vieillissant
les stocks ont grossi et bien j'ai
réussi à composer une connexion
importante
qui se lève maintenant à
33650 billets
pas mal non plus c'est une petite bague
avec des petites mains on peut se
demander à quoi ça sert et bien c'est un
film cigarette
cette fois des collectionneurs est la
cinquième c'est une foire qui connaît de
plus en plus de succès puisque cette
année elle se déroule sur deux weekends
il y aura environ 300 exposants sur
l'ensemble des week-end les
collectionneurs eux ne pourront
participer qu'une seule fois et je suis
refusé à peu près une centaine
d'exposants malgré tout le Hit Parade de
la collection qu'est-ce qui marche le
mieux d'accord postal la carte postale
de loin de loin et en second en second
je pense que le militaria marche bien
aussi de nombreux collectionneurs
s'intéressent et puis et puis la
numismatique bien sûr la philatélie les
jouets un peu toutes les autres
collections ensuite je n'ose pas vous
dire qu'est-ce qui marche le moins bien
non ça je répondrai pas
hostal chercher vous
trouvez facilement j'en trouve encore
oui vous en avez combien déjà
des centaines
déjà les paysages qu'il a peint
tous les gens qui sont décentralisés sur
Paris recherchent un petit peu leur
région
donc tous les départements sont demandés
qu'est-ce qu'on demande surtout
le centre de la France beaucoup le midi
également
et Paris bien sûr
et quelles sont les brides
de 5 francs il y a pas de marge puisque
si on après on peut tomber également
dans les
illustrateurs alors là il y a une
fourchette de prix très ouverte
tellement ouverte cette fourchette
qu'elle peut monter allègrement de 4 à 5
francs à 1000 francs si non plus ce qui
expliquerait les difficultés rencontrées
quand il s'est agit d'interroger un
marchand face à la caméra souhaitons
pour ce commerce lucratif qu'aucun
percepteur ne soit jamais lui-même un
collectionneur averti alors cet
instrument se poursuit vous avez des
nostalgiques vous château de vos
ancêtres ou par les beaux soirs de thé
les grenouilles chantent dans les fossés
en souvenir de votre enfant le chant des
grenouilles
[Musique]
ma collection comme vous le voyez toute
collection de coeurs j'ai commencé cette
collection il y a quelques années en
fait le but de cette collection c'est
des objets de la vie quotidienne il y a
des moules en forme de cœur il y a des
égouttoirs en forme de cœur il y a des
piquets épingles des il y a des
cendriers il y a des assiettes en fait
le but c'est les formes différentes et
surtout l'utilité des cas je veux pas de
cœur qui servent à rien ça m'intéresse
pas
[Musique]